well um the thing with it is uh I
brought one and two before
um never finished them so amazing yeah
really okay it's always something that
comes out
so right now you know this comes out and
guess what
high five comes out it's always
something and it's like okay I'll get to
it before back in the days
when when
you don't really pay any mind you get
into this cult-like habit of I gotta get
it first I got to get it that day like
you have to pick it up to be part of
some some group some some fake group
nobody cares bro if you coughed or not
we are selfish as Gamers I'm playing
what I won't play first I don't care I'm
playing myself I don't care if you went
to the store and did whatever that's
your business right for sure it's my
system I put it what I want let's go
continue again if we wait